en vídeos anteriores nos hemos referido
al producto interno bruto pib como el
valor final del mercado de los bienes y
servicios producidos en un país durante
un periodo de tiempo determinado por
ejemplo un año pusimos el ejemplo de la
producción de pantalones de mezclilla
donde el agricultor produce algodón
luego el fabricante de hilo toma el
algodón y produce hilo luego el
fabricante de mezclilla toma el hilo y
produce la mezclilla luego el fabricante
de pantalones toma la mezclilla y
produce pantalones y luego el valor
final de mercado de esos pantalones es
de 50 pesos supongamos que todo esto
ocurre en un año que es el periodo para
el cual vamos a medir el producto
interno bruto si lo que queremos es el
valor final del mercado de los bienes y
servicios solo vamos a tomar en cuenta
esos 50 pesos y diremos que el pib al
menos para este ejemplo de pib de esos
pantalones es de 50 pesos
sin embargo quiero aclarar que existe al
menos otra manera de medir el pib
podemos pensar en él desde el enfoque de
valor agregado pero lo importante es que
sin importar como midamos el pib debemos
obtener el mismo resultado
pensemos pues en los diversos
participantes de este proceso y cuál es
su valor agregado veamos primero al
agricultor lo voy a encerrar en un
rectángulo
este es el agricultor
cuál es su valor agregado antes este
agricultor solo tenía su tierra y sus
herramientas y podríamos decir que su
valor de mercado era cero luego produjo
algodón y ahora tiene un valor de
mercado de 10 pesos entonces su valor
agregado son 10 pesos de aquí el algodón
pasa el fabricante de hilo
el fabricante de hilo toma este algodón
que vale 10 pesos y produce hilo con un
valor de mercado de 20 pesos cuál es su
valor agregado si este fabricante toma
algo que vale 10 pesos y puede
convertirlo en algo que vale 20 pesos su
valor agregado serán otros 10 pesos
el hilo producido por este fabricante
pasa al fabricante de tela y me parece
que ya sabes hacia dónde se dirige todo
esto el fabricante de tela es esta parte
del proceso este es el fabricante de
tela cuál es su valor agregado pausa el
vídeo y trata de averiguarlo el
fabricante de tela toma algo que vale 20
pesos y lo convierte en algo que tiene
un valor de mercado de 30 pesos entonces
su valor agregado también son 10 pesos
finalmente esta es la empresa que
manufactura pantalones es el fabricante
de pantalones y este fabricante de
pantalones toma algo que tiene un valor
de mercado de 30 pesos y lo convierte en
algo que va a vender a 50 pesos entonces
cuando toma algo que vale 30 pesos y
hace que valga 50 pesos este fabricante
está sumando un valor agregado de 20
pesos
por lo tanto para obtener el pib desde
el enfoque de valor agregado
simplemente sumamos estas cantidades
entonces tenemos 10 pesos del agricultor
más 10 pesos del valor agregado del
fabricante de hilo más 10 pesos del
fabricante de tela más 20 pesos del
fabricante de pantalones cuál es el
resultado de esta suma bien pues 10 más
10 son 20 más 10 son 30 más 20 son 50 50
pesos afortunadamente para nosotros el
resultado de esta suma es la misma
cantidad que obtuvimos antes cuando
examinamos el valor final del mercado de
los bienes y servicios ahora bien un
beneficio del enfoque de valor agregado
es que las cadenas de suministros reales
son muy complejas y los productos pueden
pasar de un país a otro como dijimos en
otro vídeo el año puede terminar justo
aquí
entonces cuando algo está fabricado en
china tiene un valor agregado en china
pero luego es enviado a eeuu y allí
obtiene otro valor agregado y luego es
enviado de vuelta a china oa mexico
entonces hay que tener cuidado de solo
contabilizar el valor agregado en el
país del que estamos midiendo el pib
esta es una de las maneras en que el
enfoque de valor agregado puede ser útil
sin embargo lo importante es que debemos
obtener el mismo valor que el valor
final de mercado de los bienes y
servicios producidos en un periodo de
tiempo determinado hasta el próximo
vídeo